quelque chose a changé quand j'ai
commencé à raconter mon histoire
l'impression d'être né pour l'été la
longue je crois que j'ai fini par perdre
espoir
c'est là que j'ai commencé à perdre mes
cheveux ça va aller je suis là
j'ai retrouvé mes cheveux et confiance
en moi
je voudrais vendre vos produits je doute
que la vente soit vos cordes
ce que veulent les femmes de couleur
c'est être comme moi ils n'y arriveront
jamais mais l essai
je refuse de voir ma femme se rabaisser
j'ai pris la décision de fabriquer mon
copain fortifiant
approché je ne reçois aucun ordre manche
où lincoln a fait de moi un vieillard de
cet homme libre sera payé à tuer ma bru
préféré est ce que tu le savais chef
vous aimez vos cheveux ils ne nous
laissent rien faire on se sent l'aide
parce que c'est ce qu'ils nous font
croire avoir de beaux cheveux ouvre de
grandes perspectives maman
l'ate est dans son élément je vais créer
toute une gamme de soin et c'est pour ça
que je souhaite ouvrir ma propre et
c'est tout sauf beaucoup trop vite et
nous vivons dans un monde régi par les
hommes
nous avons choisi notre place n'est pas
venu pour faire des sandwiches je suis
venu pour faire des affaires au jeu
c'est qu'est ce que tu comptes faire
sera ne laisse passer un grade de volée
tes rêves moment
faut un plan b je ne ferai plus là les
films a fait des sacrifices c'est à ton
tour tu va foncer à ta famille et je
veux sans la beauté et cheveux sans une
femme ça tu veux développer un empire
c'est ça le grand que ceux de carnets
gifford et rockefeller
doit travailler dur
être maligne
il te fneeq riches
armengaud la guerre